have you ever felt like no matter what
you do there's just not enough time in
the day to learn your target language
I've been there too luckily with a few
small adjustments I believe it's
possible to not just squeeze language
learning into your day but to actually
make more time to get the job done keep
watching and I'll show you how hi I'm
Lucas I'm a Language Coach who speaks 14
languages and on this channel I help
people learn foreign languages faster
more efficiently and in a fun way let's
Dive Right In my own experience and my
experience coaching hundreds of language
Learners I found that when you say you
have no time for learning you're usually
making a series of mistakes that only
make it seem like you have no time if
these mistakes are addressed you will
likely discover that you had a lot more
time for language learning than you
originally anticipated
these mistakes are as follows one
telling yourself you have no time to
learn two believing that language
learning is All or Nothing
three learning when your energy is low
and when your energy is high
four waiting for motivation to strike
five making it difficult to get started
each day
6. not connecting your learning to your
other daily habit mistake number one
telling yourself you have no time to
learn the first thing to tackle is the
belief that you have no time at all for
language learning I understand that you
likely have lots of commitments work
family friends and more but I truly
believe that if you were to sit down and
really examine your typical day you'd
find more than enough productive time
each day to seriously learn a language
I'll talk more later about how much time
is enough time for language learning but
for now trust me when I say that your
schedule is likely not so packed that
you cannot learn at all
it may sound harsh but in most cases the
thought that you have no time to learn
languages is an excuse or what I like to
call a limiting belief it's simply
something you tell yourself to light
yourself off the hook for not
accomplishing a personal goal
fortunately this is something that is
fixable with practice next time you
catch yourself thinking that you do not
have time for languages stop yourself
and try to replace that thought with
another such as languages are not my
priority when you start framing language
learning as something you do or do not
prioritize you will begin to feel more
agency over whether or not the job gets
done if you think language learning is
not my priority you will naturally
stumble upon the follow-up question how
could I make language learning a
priority from there you will actively
start looking for ways to fit language
learning into your life and when you do
I'm almost certain that you will find
them but it all starts with abandoning
the belief that you do not have enough
time once you do that the real work can
begin mistake number two believing the
language learning is All or Nothing once
people realize that they actually do
have time for language learning no
matter how busy they actually might be
the next issue is one of ambition when
learning a language nearly everyone
wants to get good fast those kinds of
results typically require multiple hours
of learning per day so lots of Learners
fall into the Trap of thinking that that
is the cost of success that they must
spend several hours of learning each day
or well it's simply not worth it I'll
tell you right now that that mentality
is probably the biggest destroyer of
people's language learning dreams they
have as I'll share in a moment perfectly
good time blocks in their day for
language learning but they convince
themselves that it's not enough and
therefore they should not move forward
while I agree that spending more time on
language learning will generally lead to
faster results the truth is that for
most people spending anywhere from 30
minutes to one hour each day in language
learning is more than ideal in fact I
think it's okay to do even less than
that say 15 to 30 minutes so long as you
can do it consistently 30 minutes of
life was running a day for six months
might sound less impressive than three
hours a day for three weeks but the
reality is that for most people it's
much more manageable and much less
likely to lead to burnout and
considering how challenging language
learning can some sometimes be burnout
is something you want to avoid at all
costs mistake number three learning when
your energy is low
let's say that you're following along
and have decided to spend somewhere from
30 to 60 minutes each day learning your
target language
this is a great start but we're far from
done because now that you have some time
for learning we want to make sure that
it's high quality time which will allow
you to learn as much as possible
first we'll begin with energy levels
this might sound an obvious one but it's
something that is very often overlooked
by Learners as they go about their
language tasks but the time we reach
adulthood most of us have a pretty good
grasp of our general energy patterns if
you identify as a morning person for
example you already know that you tend
to have lots of energy early in the day
which tends to taper off towards the
evening if you identify as a night owl
on the other hand you know that you're
most productive and energy filled Hours
come in late afternoon and evening
if you fall into one of these common
patterns you should schedule your daily
language learning so that it takes place
during your Peak energy time
I'm a morning person for example so I
make sure I do my language learning
activities right after I wake up this
allows me to learn when I'm most alert
most focused and in the best possible
mood for the task if by contrast I
decided to learn at night I'd likely be
tired unfocused and quite frankly
disengaged for what I'm trying to do so
do your best to identify which times a
day are your typical high energy periods
and then schedule your language learning
at those times doing this will literally
help you learn more effectively and help
you squeeze the most value out of your
learning sessions that you would
otherwise consider short mistake number
four waiting for motivation to strike
another common issue I've encountered in
myself and others is the Insidious
desire to let your motivation tell you
when it is and it is not time to learn
let me explain for most people whether
or not they actually sit down and learn
a language is decided by a simple mental
flow chart
do I feel like learning today
if yes then I'll learn
if not then I will not learn
following this formula motivation is a
prerequisite for Action if you have
motivation you take action and if not
well maybe you'll try again tomorrow
thinking of language learning in this
way often prompts Learners to look for a
source of infinite motivation if they
only had such a fuel of source they
would learn every single day I'm sorry
to say that such an infinite source of
motivation does not exist there are ways
to increase motivation but no ways to
keep it going forever heck even I have
days where I do not feel like learning
at all what separates successful
Learners from unsuccessful ones is the
mental flow chart
whereas yours is probably similar to the
one pictured above mine goes a little
bit more like this do I feel like
learning today if yes then I learn
if not then I will learn anyway I don't
depend on motivation to take action
because as author Hall erlet states by
taking action the action itself will
produce the feelings and motivation you
need to follow through so don't let
motivation be a prereq visit for Action
instead flip the formula on its head and
let action be a prerequisite for
motivation
mistake number five making it difficult
to get started each day have you ever
sat down to learn only to realize that
you do not know what to do you do not
know where to start you do not know
where any of your resources are language
learning is not exactly the kind of
activity you can do at the drop of a hat
before you can start learning you need
to prepare and make sure you have
everything you need to learn efficiently
otherwise you risk wasting all of your
valuable learning time getting ready to
learn and spend little to none of it
productively engaging with your target
language
a key trait of a master language learner
is the ability to consistently start
once learning sessions every day to do
this you need to become skilled at
reducing any friction in your
environment that makes it difficult or
less appealing for you to begin a
learning session at your schedule time
so sometime before each learning session
it's best to do some prep work
establishing what you're going to learn
on a given day and which resources
you're going to learn with it's also a
good idea to regularly clear your
learning space of any distractions such
as phones or other devices you're not
using to learn personally I like to do
the Sprite work on Sundays before I
start my language learning tasks for a
given week I determine exactly what
materials and activities I will do each
day during that week and also set up my
space so that I have everything I need
to learn with when the time comes no
matter what language you're learning or
which learning activities you like to
engage in most make it easy to start
each session is another way to make sure
that anytime you dedicate to language
learning is useful and productive
mistake number six not connecting your
learning to your other daily habits
building on the last mistake of not
making it easy to learn I find that
people are often unaware that they can
use their existing daily routines to
make their language learning routines
more natural and effortless to remove
the friction of starting in a clear
repeatable way I recommend using
something called anchoring anchoring is
done through connecting your daily
learning Habit to a pre-existing habit
that you do each and every day since the
pre-existing habit is already a
well-established part of your routine it
serves as an anchor for your new
learning habit you just need to follow
the simple formula of after I do my
anchor habit I will sit down to learn
this formula eliminates friction by
introducing automaticity your learning
habit will always follow your anchor
habit no matter what
if you want to you can even set
anchoring to chain habits together and
make it more likely that all of them
will take place on a daily basis
naturally this habit change should also
include your daily learning sessions
personally I've used this technique to
build some long and reliable habit
chains over the years nowadays for
example this is how I spend my mornings
the first thing I do after I wake up is
making my bed after that I write in my
journal and after writing a journal I do
meditation for 10 minutes after
meditation I exercise and after exercise
I study my current target language you
can use anchoring to create habit chains
that are as long or as short as you want
the important thing is to always make
sure that you mentally connect your
language habits to at least one thing
that you do every day without fail it's
that simple
and that's it those are the six common
mistakes preventing you from having
enough time to learn a language let's
quickly review them mistake number one
telling yourself you have no time to
learn mistake number two believing that
language learning is All or Nothing
mistake number three learning when your
energy is low
mistake number four waiting for
motivation to strike
mistake number five making it difficult
to get started each day and mistake
number six not connecting your learning
to your other daily habits if you follow
the tips I've given in this video for
avoiding or reversing these mistakes you
will find that you suddenly have the
ability to create productive language
learning time where you may not have had
any before try them out and let me know
how I went by leaving a comment below
and if you'd like to learn even more
about how to fit powerful language
learning strategies into each and every
day be sure to check out the courses it
might become a master language learner
series I've gotten one course for
beginners and another for intermediate
Learners so there are useful tips that
nearly anyone can apply anyway thanks
for watching and as always happy
language learning